the narrative taught to us by
Egyptologists about the truth of ancient
human civilization particularly that of
ancient Egyptians is so full of holes
that they are now quite literally
debunking themselves in fact you may
have seen news articles making headlines
around the world of how researchers have
decoded the genome of ancient Egyptians
for the very first time in fact the
findings have turned years of theory on
its head causing Egyptologists to
re-evaluate the region's history
altogether the study tested preserved
remains from an archaeological site
along the Nile River in middle Egypt
then compared the DNA to modern
Egyptians in Cairo the study found that
the mummies closest ancient relatives
were from the Near East or West Asia and
Europe so in other words modern
Egyptians have more in common with
sub-saharan Africa than the ancient
Egyptians do which just completely
debunked everything they thought they
knew about the human migration process
into ancient Egypt and elsewhere around
the world now it's worth mentioning that
they did testing from just one site in
middle Egypt for more than 150 Egyptian
mummies now obviously they need to do
more testing from other sites but it
almost tells me that they chose this
site just to validate their current
narrative I mean any research you do on
this you'll see just how shocked these
people truly were to have these findings
but why are these people always so
shocked I mean we learn throughout
history that we constantly debunk
ourselves that what we knew yesterday
turns out to be false tomorrow and these
people just can't seem to wrap their
minds around it maybe it's because of
the fact that they memorized definitions
and textbook decades ago and they've
been handing out degrees on the subject
matter which is as we've learned full of
falsehoods for decades that they've been
handing out these degrees to tens of
thousands of people but they just don't
want to accept the fact that well
they've been wrong from the get-go and
we've already learned in just the last
year and a half that they're finding
Native American DNA to contain
middle-eastern DNA which is just a
complete shock and a complete mystery
and on top of that they're finding DNA
and South American mummies that have DNA
from Aborigines from Australia I mean
you could pretty much just take the
known human migration pattern map and
throw it out the window because it has
just been overwhelmingly debunked I mean
how
in the world do you have Australian
Aboriginal DNA in South American mummies
but not in the remains of North American
Indians I've discussed this in other
videos but it just goes to show you that
quite literally BVD apologists have no
idea what they're talking about I mean
how do they explain the fact that there
are tens of thousands of ancient
Egyptian petroglyphs and hieroglyphs
that show the ancient Egyptians or
dynastic Egyptians I should say doing
all kinds of different things yet
there's a complete lack zero information
whatsoever about how they built the
Great Sphinx or the pyramids all
together which further validates when
you take this newfound DNA evidence that
there was indeed a cataclysm that reset
ancient human civilizations so whoever
built the Sphinx and the pyramids well
they were wiped out during last
Cataclysm 13,000 years ago and the
dynastic Egyptians that we know of came
and found the remains of these ancient
sites and just built on top of them I've
discussed the overwhelming evidence of
the Cataclysm in multiple other videos
so I'll just hold off there but just to
paint you a picture I've discussed this
in other videos as well but when you
look at the overwhelming evidence from
the enclosure of the Great Sphinx it
proves that the age of the Great Sphinx
is at least double the age of what we've
been taught and very likely to be tens
of thousands of years old based on the
water erosion around it I mean anyone
that doesn't acknowledge us has either
not looked at the research or is lying
just to protect their own financial
incentives because the evidence is
overwhelmingly conclusive that yes
the Great Sphinx is far older than what
we've been taught in school or the
narrative that the Egyptologist have
been teaching for decades in fact you
have professional geologists take for
example Robert Schoch and more than 200
other professional geologists from
around the world dozens of countries
that have evaluated the Sphinx and have
said that yes it looks like there might
be twenty to thirty thousand years of
water erosion around it which it's worth
mentioning that there is more than
thirty thousand years of Egyptian
lineage from the Pharaohs literally
carved in stone throughout ancient Egypt
and yet modern Egyptologists just blow
that off and say it's symbolism of
something else that it's wrong that
obviously we don't date back thirty
thousand years that's just impossible we
don't have the evidence the evidence is
right in front of you and how long I
mean how many times these people have to
be debunked for them to register the
fact that maybe there's a lot more that
they don't know than they know
it's time to start asking new questions
it's time as they start acknowledging
all the overwhelming evidence of the
Cataclysm that happened eleven thousand
six hundred years ago and thirteen
thousand years ago that shows you that
there was an advanced civilization of
some kind that existed and they were
wiped out following that Cataclysm and
hence the reason why we don't know
anything that happened more than 6,000
years ago yet modern humans as we are
today have existed for at least one
hundred fifty thousand years possibly as
much as three hundred three hundred
fifty thousand years as we saw in recent
articles going around which I discussed
in another video I mean you ever wonder
why we just have zero knowledge dating
back more than six thousand years and
even 6,000 years ago with totally foggy
and there's limited information about
that altogether like I said it's time to
start asking new questions but clearly
the true history of ancient human
civilization is far older and we were
far more advanced than we were ever
taught in school anyways guys I'm Jimmy
this is bright insight like and
subscribe leave me a comment let me know
what your thoughts are and I have many
other videos to come and a whole wide
variety of topics take care everybody